J'ai 24 ans et je crois que j'ai tout compris aux filles
FAUX
Plus ça va,  et plus je me dis que les filles, c'est des extraterrestres.
Des ovnis...
Elles ont un comportement assez bizarre
Elles communiquent quand même avec les animaux
Sergie, tu arrêtes de pisser partout par terre
Alors que le chat il va pas lui répondre
Ah excuse moi ! Désolé, j'ai pas fait exprès.
Bon la prochaine fois, j'ferai pipi dans la litière.
Elles ont aussi une technologie d'avance par rapport à nous...
elles utilisent des armes...
de torture !
*musique inquiétante*
AHAHAHAH
NOOOOOOON !
Ce que j'essaie de vous dire tant bien que mal...
c'est qu'elles veulent MANGER les humains.
Je l'ai vu.
Je l'ai entendu.
"Coucou !
Oh il est trop mignon j'ai envie de le bouffer !
*musique inquiétante*
Elles ont des conversations secrètes entre elles
qu'elles veulents pas nous faire partager.
(Je crois qu'elles préparent un plan maléfique)
- Pourquoi ?
- Bah... euh...
- AH ! oui, d'accord.
Moi c'est cette nuit que ça arrive.
Qu'est-ce qui arrive cette nuit ?
- Euh... rien, non non.
*musique inquiétante*
C'est bizarre.
Nous on a deux bras, deux jambes
mais elles elles ont des membres cachés, qu'elles ne montrent jamais !
Ça se remarque, par exemple, quand elles prennent leur douche.
- Tiens, tu me passe la serviette bleue s'il te plait ?
merci
Tu me passe la serviette orange ?
Tiens passe moi la serviette verte
*musique inquiétante*
Je sais que c'est difficile à croire, moi même quand je me suis rendu compte de ça
je me suis pris une sacrée claque.
Qu'elles parlent anglais, français, arabe ou tchèque
elles ont un langage... entre elles
que nous on peut pas comprendre.
Alors, à force de les côtoyer,
j'ai essayé de...
de trouver une traduction.
de manière à peu près approximative.
Ah il est trop beau ce collier !
*rire gêné*
Il m'irai trop bien en plus avec ma couleur de peau !
Ouais... naaan... c'est vulgaire...
Bah pourquoi tu dis ça ?
J'sais pas... euh... toi tu... c'est pas ton style.
Elles sont peut être dangereuses, hein !
Faut se protéger.
Alors moi, à un moment donné j'avais pensé à une technique.
(mais en fait c'était pas une bonne idée)
Personne AU MONDE ne peut prétendre connaître l'étendue de leurs pouvoirs.
Elles peuvent peut être faire des trucs de ouf qu'on n'imagine même pas !
*musique intrigante et bruits de laser*
!!!
Et enfin le plus effrayant c'est dans les toilettes des filles.
*grincement de porte*
Elles ont un truc que nous on n'a pas
c'est une petite poubelle placée à côté de la cuvette
qu'il ne faut JA-MAIS ouvrir.
*musique effrayante*
*scream*
Jamais.
Nous voulons juste pratiquer l'amour avec vous.
De manière protégée.
S'il vous plait.
Heureusement vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux sur ma page facebook "Norman fait des vidéos"
ça me fait trop plaisir.
A bientôt !
Et sortez couverts !